[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24
redes de tráfico sexual que operan entre
venezuela y trinidad y tobago son
nuestro tema de hoy los crímenes de los
que son víctimas principalmente mujeres
adultas y menores de edad venezolanas se
potencian conforme aumenta la
vulnerabilidad de las poblaciones en
crisis económica y social un problema
que se acrecentó con la pandemia sin
recursos para sobrevivir en casa de
estas mujeres son llevadas ilegalmente
con engaños al país insular atendiendo
promesas de empleo y estudios son
embarcadas en un viaje peligroso por mar
y si sobreviven son vendidas a esquemas
de prostitución
a ellos quién los protege quién los
rescata esa es nuestra discusión de hoy
y vamos a la historia con la
investigación de insight prime
para llegar a trinidad y tobago desde
venezuela por vía ilegal hay que
atravesar el golfo de paria es un viaje
peligroso patrocinado por redes de
tráfico ilegal en lanchas de madera en
mal estado y que se mueven de noche las
posibilidades de naufragio son altas y
abundan las noticias de migrantes
fallecidos en el intento porque se van
muchos emprenden la travesía
desesperados en busca de mejor vida y
huyendo de la crisis de venezuela y si
yo por lo menos ahorita tienen un par de
chola
tienen su ropa tienen su comida a la
hora gracias a dios
pero
mi familia yo me comunico con ella y yo
tengo muchas hermanas que tienen hijos
a veces me llaman
para que yo lo ayude porque no tienen
que darle a sus hijos en el mejor de los
casos los viajeros logran establecerse
en el país insular pero no todos están
en trinidad y tobago por voluntad propia
redes de tráfico sexual secuestran o
engañan a cientos de mujeres adultas y
niñas a diario con promesas de trabajo y
educación las embarcan precariamente y
las venden para la prostitución sus
familias no saben si sobrevivieron ni de
señora yo estoy cumpliendo con avisarle
que su hija está abogado su vida se
murió y yo como que mi hija está muerta
si el barco donde viva el bote donde iba
se hundió mi hija fue vendida desde aquí
mi hija estaba vendida desde aquí la
organización de estados américanos
denunció que pese al cierre de fronteras
por kobe 19 continuó el flujo de
venezolanos a trinidad y tobago a través
de medios irregulares y riesgosos cuando
le hablo de menores de edad escolar de
adolescentes entre los 13 años y los 17
años de edad ya en edad adulta puede ser
a partir de los 18 años hasta mujeres
que pueden tener más de 40 años víctimas
de trata y tráfico hemos podido
evidenciar con testimonios que no han
compartido víctimas que poder cuerpos de
seguridad a todo nivel local estatal y
nacional es decir policía o guardia
nacional también son parte de esta
cadena de crimen y de criminalidad
según la ong venezolana fundar redes los
migrantes también caen en manos de las
redes de trata de personas mientras
están en el mar algunas mujeres son
retenidas en trinidad y tobago y otras
son después transportadas a lugares tan
lejanos como europa del este- españa' o
áfrica del norte un informe sobre trata
de personas publicado en 2020 por el
departamento de estado de eeuu señalará
la complicidad de funcionarios
países incluidos miembros de la fuerza
pública el reportaje alertó que sólo 34
víctimas fueron identificadas entre 2019
y 2020 todas ellas excepto una nación
venezolana en el mejor de los casos el
gobierno de trinidad las atiende junto
organizaciones de derechos reciben
hospedaje asistencia jurídica servicios
médicos y apoyo para volver a casa pero
esa no es la regla el gobierno
estadounidense advirtió que tras las
redadas policiales a los lugares
relacionados con el comercio sexual
ilegal normalmente las autoridades
detienen a las víctimas por violar las
leyes de inmigración y son castigadas
mientras que los traficantes siguen
impunes
para conversar del tema está en ella soy
la periodista venezolana adriana
abramovich reportera de la revista
volcánicas
adriana bienvenida a ella soy y son tres
etapas descritas por la organización
insightcrime el reclutamiento el
transporte y la explotación cuántas
mujeres han sido víctimas de tráfico y
quién las está protegiendo
hola bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación este programa y para hablar
al instante
hay que aclarar incluye el engaño y digo
esa etapa inicial de reclutamiento
inicia en venezuela con redes sociales
es crítico porque se ve en muchas
adaptaciones ellos se dan por facebook
por instagram por las redes sociales
después de que el patrón principales son
mujeres y niñas en situación de pobreza
extrema y vulnerabilidad sabemos también
que venezuela está atravesando una
crisis humanitaria completa y se ven
afectados pues sólo el derecho al
trabajo y aunque principalmente ha sido
económica sino que también se ven
vulnerados otros hecho el derecho a la
salud derecho a la alimentación en común
frente a un estado muy crítico en el que
se encuentra la población venezolana
pues las más generales son las mujeres y
las niñas y vemos que esta etapa inicial
de tratamiento pues se da en redes
sociales
muchas personas pues ahí empiezan como a
tener un enfoque más restrictivo sobre
el uso del internet si los padres tienen
que estar on los pendientes lo que hacen
los niños en redes sociales y según la
fundación niño sin miedo realmente esto
no es algo que va a tener esta forma de
trata y de vulneración a los derechos
humanos y realmente tener las
conversaciones frontales sobre el cuerpo
la sexualidad de la autoestima son las
que pueden ir abonando un terreno más
seguro para que los hogares sean estos
primeros lugares en donde las mujeres
puedan sentirse tranquilas y no sientan
la necesidad de unirse a por violencia
intrafamiliar o porque son víctimas de
estas violencias trata claro si hay
algún problema adrián además de fondo es
el hambre la pobreza la desesperación la
necesidad que deja a las mujeres sin
caminos para ejercer o para trabajar y
que terminan en actividades de
prostitución por la fuerza o incluso a
veces pues porque no hay más que hacer
usted ha denunciado con mucha fuerza
como se sitúen un informe del estado de
eeuu que las autoridades
las protegen las judicial y salas de
portan y las dejan aún más vulnerables y
los proxenetas que
de acuerdo es que eso siempre ha sido un
tema y acá se habla de una triangulación
perfecta entre los capitales que
normalmente lideran estos botes y estos
estos traslados de mujeres migrantes
también los grupos armados y los grupos
criminales que están custodiando la zona
y también se habla de una alianza que es
la que logra esa triangulación que son
los funcionarios de la policía y las
autoridades migratorias que logran y que
ahora en este terreno esto es algo
supremamente preocupante porque así es
muy difícil dar con las redes trata es
muy difícil también aportar y brindar la
asistencia que necesitan las víctimas de
trata después de que se hace una
denuncia de este estilo entonces el
apoyo de las autoridades ha sido como el
gran ausente en estas redes de trata y
hablando también de las tensiones y las
expulsiones no solamente arbitrarias y
no colectivas se habla de detenciones
desde el 2019
nada de parte de la policía donde logran
identificar estas redes de trata y en
vez de agarrar a los tratantes y
someterlos a la justicia pues lo que
hacen es deportar a mujeres venezolanas
y expulsarla sin que se les garantice el
debido proceso sin que formen parte de
estos programas de asistencia
psicológica sino que más bien las
revisan y siguen vulnerando los derechos
y regresando los al país en el que están
yendo y de las que son víctimas
el primer ministro de trinidad y tobago
keith rowley dijo que el aumento del
tráfico de emigrantes y de redes de
prostitución hacia su país era culpa de
la oea por disparar la crisis con sus
ataques contra el gobierno de venezuela
usted qué opina de esa acusación de
quién es la culpa
no yo creo que acá más que poner
culpables hay que saber que venezuela
pues hay un régimen dictatorial desde
hace más de 20 años que hacerse de las
tapas y pues nunca ha aceptado que
vienes vela hay respecto una crisis está
haciendo que ya el 20 por ciento de la
población haya migrado más de cinco
millones de personas me hablase al
principio de las cifras y se habla de
veintiún mil mujeres que han sido
víctimas de trata desde venezuela esta
es una cifra muy preocupante estamos
hablando de pues de derechos
fundamentales que serían vulnerados
entonces más que poner acá cargas de
quién es el culpable estamos hablando de
unas autoridades que son ineficientes en
su labor de protección a las mujeres en
este caso son mujeres en situación de
pobreza y vulnerabilidad del patrón son
mujeres menores de edad según la
organización de naciones unidas contra
la droga y el delito
de las 10 personas que son víctimas de
trata siete son mujeres cinco de ellas
son adultas y dos niñas esto es una
cifra pues muy preocupante que evidencia
la situación de vulnerabilidad en la que
nos encontramos las mujeres migrantes
venezolanas mire yo sé que el medio
feminista volcánica se para el que usted
trabaja ha sido realmente muy fuerte y
abogando mucho por el legalizar la
prostitución esta es una discusión larga
y además de difícil que se enfrenta
directamente con el abolicionismo yo no
le voy a pedir que entremos en esa
conversación que por ahora es muy
desgastante sino más bien le quiero
preguntar ciertamente el tráfico de
personas es causa y consecuencia del
negocio de la prostitución ante casos
como este que hablamos usted qué opina
cuál es la solución para el problema de
fondo que es la prostitución
pues realmente el problema de fondo no
es la constitución el problema de fondo
la trata de personas y en ningún momento
vamos a estar a favor de la trata y la
explotación sexual de ningún ser humano
entonces también hay que aclarar que la
prostitución
el marco legal que querían para proteger
a las personas en su trabajo sexual más
bien debería es darles dignidad para al
momento de ejercer su labor para que
pueda ser bien remunerado en caso de
sufrir algún tipo de vulneración sea por
violencia o agresión pues puedan ir con
todas las de la ley a denunciar a sus
agresores y no se sientan en una
situación de extrema vulnerabilidad en
donde además de estar en una situación
irregular al ser la suscripción un
trabajo ilegal entonces no pueden ir y
hacer su denuncia o eso es lo que se
tiene pensado porque la prostitución ya
está por lo menos en columbia protegida
por cierto marco legal pero hay por
supuesto muchísimo desconocimiento y la
policía y los centros de salud muchas
veces no son los mejores aliados cuando
una mujer trabajadora sexual se acerca y
presentó una denuncia de este estilo
pero acá hay una diferencia muy grande
entre el trabajo sexual que es
voluntario y que debería ser remunerado
a las garantías como cualquier otro
trabajo y la trata de personas ella es
un negocio de compra y venta de mujeres
estamos hablando de que una mujer pueda
leer mil quinientos dólares de cuando
acá nuestros cuerpos son una mercancía y
se pueden codificar y se pueden vender a
otro ser humano
adriana disculpe muchas gracias se nos
acaba el tiempo y ya para finalizar
simplemente quiero tomar una frase de
sus intervenciones en redes sociales y
es que necesitamos visibilidad y
protección para las mujeres migrantes
muchas gracias a ustedes y a nuestros
televidentes por estar con nosotros en
ellas hoy sigan con nosotros
[Música]